veteran left-hander john lester yeah
he's off to a really good start a 2-0
record in three starts 1.06
his earned run averages he's in his 15th
season he's only had two losing years
hiro went around that strike three he's
gone
get down there big man call
strike three nice start
for john lester yeah josh get off to a
slow start
last time out against minnesota was a no
decision in the brewers victory
the cubs have a scoring chance right
away see if kyle can do some damage here
oh score first inning the pitch to
schwarber ground ball base sent right
center field
rounding third rizzo he's going to score
racing to third contreras he's safe
on an rbi single by kyle schwarber cubs
lead one to nothing
rbi number eight for schwarber steven
souza jr who hit his first homer
as a cub yesterday 2-2 count
the pitch into the corner
it's going to be a fair ball stays in
play
schwarber around third cubs are going to
get two
[Applause]
it's a double for souza and it's three
to nothing
[Applause]
crooked number early with john lester on
the mound the way he's been going
sure feels awfully good in that home
dugout right now
getting the rare start takes advantage
change up
up being the operative word that thing's
belt high for souza
the man leader 1-0
line drive in the right of base hit and
ureas
is swinging the best bat in the lineup
right now
the 1-1 grounded towards the middle and
through base hit for arcia
ureas will put on the brakes at second
two are on
one out two men out for casting hero
trying to get things on track gone over
his last
14. the fly ball hit back into center
field he hit it well
he just snapped out of the funk a
three-run homer for casting hero
and we are tied in the third that kid
that ball just jumps off his back
doesn't it
my goodness number five for here at a
dead center
that was a 2-2 pitch and he just hit a
bullet on out of here
the uh runner goes and here's the throw
down from manny nailed him
in half on the run and manny pina throws
him out
stealing for the second out of the end
it's an amazing throwing arm to second
base not only does he have the quick
release
gets himself watch the feed if he can
look how quickly those feet are in place
and in position that throw right on the
money i mean
unbelievable throw the brewers have two
really good throwing catchers and manny
able to catch hat
they off pitch sends one to right field
and that's going to get down and get to
the corner
maria's continues to swing the hot bat
he's on his way to second
he turns it up on his way to third and
he will get there a
triple to begin the fifth for luis
urias you just love that approach i mean
he can turn on a fastball in the pitch
before
able to pop the hands open and
pull that ball foul then he gets one up
and away
goes right with it down the right field
line and well he's been impressive so
far
and arceus swings in a drive deep to
left field
and that is out of here two-run shot
orlando arcia as the brewers take the
lead
the bottom of the order delivering today
for the brew crew yep and four for four
they've scored four runs
orlando arcia doing what he does best
picking on the first pitch
cubs trail 5-3 bases are loaded this
should be a great matchup now for
kidneys
ground ball basement cubs are going to
tie it
jason kittness
[Applause]
talk about a huge two-out knock things
were really setting up for council with
his bullpen
but kipnis ruins all of that with one
swing in the back
three and two again the pitch swinging a
rocket to center back is half still back
it's over his head
up against the ivy archie chugging for
seconds he's trying for third here comes
the relay throw it's offline
orlando arcia with a leadoff triple to
start the seventh
the relay throw from nico horner if it's
online rc is out by half a baseline
he was running out of gas as soon as he
hit second base but the throw was in the
foul ground
up the left field line and that allowed
orlando rc to get into third safely
in orlando rc is now a double away from
the cycle
go ahead run standing at third base for
ryan braun
braun is over three the pitch line shot
in the left center of base hit the
brewers regain the lead
it's 6'5 milwaukee on braun's first hit
of the afternoon
so just as the cubs came back to tie it
the brewers regained the lead within two
batters
lebron with run bannon in number three
on the season
and remember today he is in the lead-off
spot 3-2 pitch coming to wilson
contreras rizzo's running the pitch
swung on and missed
thrown down to second and that's a
strike him out throw him out
double play wicked change up
and more wicked pop time from manny pina
ending the seventh inning
96 up and in a chopper tough play hater
will make it and look out did he get
there no
wanted to tag him pulled off and then
bae is able to sneak through
and he's on amazing i mean that guy he
just finds a way to make things happen
if josh just tags him out right away or
just goes to the bag
it's an out but right there just tag him
tags him late i think the brewer is
going to take a look at it yeah i think
so
i think he's out i think he's out
and here it is two men out
25th of the inning 13th coming up to
nico horner
and a line drive center field garcia's
there and the brewers win it
oh what a battle hater versus horner
a 13 pitch at bat and josh hader with
another save as the
cubs go down in order